now to the latest twist in the elon musk
twitter saga
i want to keep you holding on the edge
of your seat we told you last week the
world's richest man recently bought a
9.2 stake in the social media company
that he has often criticized twitter
offered him a seat on the board and musk
said he was looking forward to working
with the ceo and the board but last
night twitter's ceo revealed musk passed
on the offer the day was supposed to
take effect quote i believe this is for
the best prague argo wall said adding
elon is our biggest shareholder and we
will remain open to his input musk
tweeted this early um he tweeted this
early this morning it has now been
it has now been deleted
well i mean it's so we were sort of
joking with shawna thomas our executive
producer a lot of people think elon musk
is sort of like a bond villain now that
is a very bond villain move to pull like
a little like emoji saying
he thinks outside the box it's never
boring he's always got a master game
plan i will say it's never boring is
there a master planner i don't know he
spent the weekend also disparaging and
criticizing twitter and pointing out
that some famous people don't tweet that
much and
i don't know do you want that at your
biggest show doesn't just do stuff
randomly i don't believe it elon's going
to elon i was intrigued by the he's he's
worth 273 billion dollars which guys is
a hundred billion dollars more than the
next guy on the list right that's jeff
bezos at 188 billion the number four guy
bill gates is only 133 billion with a b
i love the only question i know exactly
that's what the question is if you want
to get richer do you buy stock and
twitter at the moment i don't know based
on what tesla stock has been surging
tesla has been surging